well Moulin Rouge the musical is not
just a production it's a spectacle you
can see it now at the Smith Center and
we have two special guests with us today
please welcome Harper miles and Nikki
class Bell thank you both so much for
being here ladies thanks for having me
here so I loved the show and everyone I
talked to loves it as well and I'm
excited that people still have a chance
to continue to see it for a little while
longer but Harper I'll start with you at
Moulin Rouge it is Iconic and Tony
Awards how does it feel to be part of
this production it feels absolutely
amazing the company is fantastic
everybody just loves putting on this
amazing show it's so fun and people
leave just having a really good time
yeah that's how I felt there's confetti
that comes yeah
that was my favorite record I think if
you're talking a little bit earlier you
performed around Vegas before but this
is both of your first times performing
at the Smith Center it's so beautiful
what's the experience been like for you
it's really incredible the audiences are
so welcoming and so ready to like just
take this show on and it's it is like
you said like the confetti happens like
kind of bookends the show and there's
real heart to it and so um I think
everyone's being really really really
receptive to it I mean the moment you
walk into the theater and just seeing
the stage waiting there you know it's
about to be a spectacle truly and Harper
what are you most excited for people to
see in the show uh just all of well
first off all of the popular songs that
everyone knows and loves that really
gets the people going and just the just
the talent that we have on the stage
it's so amazing and Beyond
um anything that I've ever been in for
sure well I'm speaking of talent you
guys travel all over you probably have
become a close family is there anything
fun that kind of goes on behind the
stage or backstage or any moments that
you can kind of share with us I guess
you know we we always try to keep it
interesting and keep it fun after doing
this for almost a year so far sometimes
we'll have little secret games on stage
like whisper this to somebody like I
gave a telephone but like nothing that's
gonna disrupt the show but just keep it
fresh for us yeah keep it exciting and
for everyone one that comes to see the
show it's kind of just this moment where
you walk in you think you know the show
and then you leave there and you're just
surprised because the talent is
unbelievable the dancing the costuming I
mean what what are the costumes like
that's another one of my favorite Parts
they are so beautifully crafted I mean
every little detail is just so beautiful
and it's amazing to to be in them we
have one scene where we're in these
beautiful costumes for like five seconds
on stage but they're so gorgeous they're
really great I loved all of the Sparkles
and the champagne that was being served
and it really sets the tone so ladies
thank you so much for being here
congrats on the show thank you I still
want to see it I promise you will love
it it is running through February 5th
all the information is on your screen be
sure to get your tickets for the Smith
Center